so i'm here with oh my god i am
so bad with names what is your name
again i'm insulted
i am so alyssa yeah alyssa ferrari
isn't that cool what the the most badass
name
i literally met her like 15 minutes ago
i
um posted an ad on craigslist and i was
like we need hot chicks to come on the
show
and then she replied right away it was
crazy was it broadway
yeah no not right away it was like like
two weeks after i was like i forgot i
posted this
yeah which sounds
why did you come along so because we
were having fun on the phone
that is that is how all bad craigslist
stories
i cannot believe you went along with
this melissa
just met her and i was like we have a
few things in common quite a few
actually and i want to get to know her
while we're on
camera what it's like what other fun way
to really do an interview this is real
interview [ __ ]
i don't have like prepared questions
you're going to watch this you can't
fake this
honey and you know me when there's a hot
girl
you gotta hit on her ain't that right
alyssa
for sure i've been hitting on her all
night that's what i do
anyway look there's a few things we have
in common how italian are you she's
italian
i'm italian you're like full italian i'm
not full italian actually
i'm italian polish french
irish austrian and
some other things that i know i'm
forgetting that i've no i shouldn't
forget but they're there
whoa so are you like half italian my
dad's side is italian my mom's side is
more mixed
okay so you are like 50 like me not so
much but yes it's
more toward the larger end okay this is
slowly getting more depressing as we
continue we're more alike than you think
you're separating
separating things there's that blood
bond of italian-ness
that you know other people they can't
connect on that level yeah you actually
know what she's right you just need like
a small bit
of italian blood and you're like i feel
you if you're italian you know
you just know it no when she walked
through the door i was like are you
italian
about the feature film thingy i did cool
it's called mary and i am mary nice
yeah it is a jesus christ story it's
about a girl
who has never been laid
her roommate stole her a party but that
is a goal and she makes a
very big mistake very big are you having
like actual sex scenes
it's implied it's implied but you don't
see it and
you'll see you'll see you'll see when it
comes okay all right okay
i hope we get to see it is this a
national lampoon movie you'll see you'll
all see
it'll be fun but uh and you're the main
character yeah wow that's
crazy i'm excited dude okay so i really
hope there's a sex scene of you i would
love to do a trailer reaction to that
[ __ ] i have to be here for that though
because i want to see it you know
firsthand yeah you can just watch my
face the whole time yeah
staring intently just just watching
every little twitch i'm reacting while
you're reacting
awesome check this [ __ ] out man she
plays dance central three
yes all my sweet moves
and then are you like picking the tree
is that what that was no
shopping cart like she saw i have dances
for three and in case you guys don't you
know what i'm gonna show you the video
that i did i saw the case on the floor
and i kind of flipped out i had a mini
mini flip out in my brain and that came
out of my mouth as
oh my god we need to do this and in turn
he was like oh my god you know this i
guess i know this
we need to do this yeah we should it
kind of spiraled i feel like
the way you talk you're talking for deaf
people with your hands you are the most
expressive italian hands i have
ever seen it's happening it's the
italian thing man i only know italian
cliches
like pepperoni
you watch family guy where do you think
i got that dude
how hot is she i feel like this guy's
going to be my new best friend that's
what's going to happen
there's no way that's not we have too
much in common for
it to not happen like that hey say your
austrian shout out
[ __ ] dude i forgot your youtube
username but the dude is from austria
goose
goosebumps 83 or some [ __ ] i think goose
eggs i forgot what your name is
something with a goose something with a
goose
so in case you guys don't know i did a
video of me dancing in my underwear
to dance central three hey that rhyme
did you hear that i i heard it i did a
video of me dancing in my underwood at
dance central three
so you could rap right now i gotta go pp
because i really gotta go to the
bathroom
you're italian you should be my groom oh
[ __ ] i'm actually ramen a lot
it's probably because i got a girl in
front of me who's so damn hot oh
what up now that was kind of epic i
didn't that was impossible that was cool
hell yeah i didn't even plan that [ __ ] i
didn't that's not written that was spit
in
oh yeah i just ran again oh we got a
youtube notification
oh oh anthony carbo what's up man just
read your reaction
hey diane ghetto i'm talking to you
right now oh yeah
here we go you ready for this [ __ ] i'm
ready i'm sorry i was born ready
all right here we go hi i'm ryan i used
to be in pretty good shape but i need to
lose something
did you add that were you actually like
very sweaty i was
i want to show you some stuff i've
learned
because i've got moves like jagger
yes
here we go
i'm so sexy that's what i think when i
watch my stuff i think yeah
i mean look at that
you're my new favorite person i love you
so much right now
i'm kind of impressed right now i
thought it was just going to be like
random flailing but now you're actually
like what are you doing yeah that's what
i've committed
i love it i love it i love it i love it
i love it i love it
really though if you haven't seen it
that was kind of the most amazing thing
that has
graced my eyeballs in a while
i could show you something else that'll
grace your eyeballs
hey now where did we just go we're
getting a little raunchy in here aren't
we
yeah and she got in shape with dan
central three that's crazy
i'm gonna commit every day to doing dan
central three
and you mofos are gonna see my weight
loss pitches wanna see the before and
afters oh
she has before and after photos that's
before yo
let me hold this she's in a bikini all
right
so you can see there are some problem
areas that need to be addressed you
still got a core though
well i mean but that was me what like 25
30 pounds ago
yeah i could definitely see it okay and
then this is me now
whoa damn
i gotta keep this image in my mind
tonight before i go to bed
um this whoa that's what you look like
underneath all that
yeah yeah i mean there aren't a whole
lot of layers going on here but yeah
damn dude i'm getting is that you yeah
side view
dude she's got oh i wish she would let
me show these she's got a really hot
body
sneaky dude you look really hot here
thank you
no i'm telling you and you even got
boobs oh
dude put this away now but i've always
had yours that's nothing new they just
got smaller
yeah well it's the italian thing italian
girls they got boobies
good for you good for you good for you
alyssa yes your name is spelled with an
a
which i like yeah because a lot of the
lists i know are with an e
whether it be alyssa not alison
yeah you [ __ ] some good footage right
here
keep going please yes
oh god yes
no enough stop it
witch sorcerer cooking up is bust a move
by young mc
i know it but i don't know the damn
damn [ __ ] dreams
i was looking at you
taking everybody down
wow
you